single single person oh my god talk
about single bed if it's attached to a
nice person okay what about is
[Applause]
back to their hoop so you're looking for
a nice guy is what you said not in that
order
no nice can come last yeah I just just
my wife's always assured me that doesn't
matter
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you know nice yeah yeah big
things medium so you're out there you're
on the scene you're looking around you
are you doing that are you dating on the
on the media on the I'm on life dating
apps I'm on tinder
bamba Raya hinge OkCupid that's six I'm
sad it's so hard I just it's just
someone said oh thank you thank you
that's someone who are you very open
about what it is you're looking for when
you're on social media yes my profile
picture has me holding like a like a
footlong dildo you know be women we just
we don't tell people what we want we're
doing why we need to be like give it to
me right I'm right with you
I don't know I don't know what happens
you tell me what to talk about Jax I
have no idea what to ask you next you
seem like a happy person how about that
you're a happy there you is you seem
very happy on television and when you're
performing are you happy in real life
clearly if the dating life isn't going
well that's would be you wouldn't be so
happy it's pretty easy to smile my
mother used to say it takes more to
frown than it does to smile so I can be
like you with a smile on my face you
know I probably shouldn't wait every
question I asked you go down a certain
but I could ask you you know what's your
favorite thing about a rainbow you know
color
[Applause]
just like in the pot of gold you know I
got a duck tail swimming in the koi and
the coin oh my god oh my god
you